nein new york times interview von gerd
schröder ein gespräch in einer schröders
büro in hannover über putin sein freund
von dem er sicher bezahlen ist über den
krieg überall die opfer kinder und
frauen was macht schröder er steht zu
putin keine distanz zu dem mann der
kriegsverbrechen begeht keine reue
nichts im winter ja das sind die bilder
so inszeniert er sich dort also in
seinem hannoveraner büro und er sagt er
diese sätze also das hätte eine hohe
interview werden könnten er sagt ich
mache jetzt nicht einen auf mehr culpa
das ist nicht mein ding sagt herr
schröder und er spricht dann weiter über
ihn sich selbst als interessenvertreter
er habe doch immer die deutschen
interessen den deutschen getreten
gedient sagt er ich tue was ich tun kann
und jetzt sagt er den entscheidenden
satz wenigstens eine seite vertraut mir
und wir können hier dreimal raten wenn
er damit meint natürlich die seite
moskaus putins seit den kreml
bei uns sind paul wir wollen einmal
gemeinsam in einem interview reinschauen
das duo geführt heisst mit vitali
klitschko den bürgermeister von kiew der
sich ganz klar geäußert hat zu diesem
statement zu diesem interview in der new
york times ja von gerd schröder dem
ex-kanzler
bekommt es gilt beim arbeiten in
russland und kriegt millionen von
gazprom vom podien man muss einfach zu
sagen welche interesse beteiligt seine
arbeitgeber
oder durch
und was betrifft
internationale rechte was betrifft
europäische werte und diese akzeptiert
man kann nicht
akzeptieren man kann nicht begreifen
man kann nicht halb schwanger zu sein
hans heinz zugeschaltet aus gift dass
dieses interview geführt und man hört
heraus die fassungslosigkeit ist
wirklich groß über dieses interview des
ex kanzlers und der vorschlag steht im
raum man kann ja nach moskau ziehen
patricia genauso ist es mit vitali
klitschko hat danach mit mir noch weiter
gesprochen und hat gesagt dann soll doch
gerhard schröder nach moskau ziehen und
er hat auch gesagt was ist eigentlich
mit seinen konten und was ist mit einer
no
fly list sozusagen für die usa also die
der druck aus der ukraine richtung gerd
schröder richtung deutschland richtung
spd der wird immer größer danke paul
ronzheimer für deine einschätzung aus
kiew und darüber wollen wir weiter
sprechen im studio über dieses seltsame
gerhard schröder interview und diese
inszenierung dort des altkanzlers in der
new york times mit unserem bild
chefreporter peter tiede grüßt sich
peter wir schauen noch mal gemeinsam auf
diese fotos drauf gerd schröder ja das
ist ja eine ganz besondere form der
inszenierung dort in der new york times
er als jahre alter machtmensch dort in
seinem büro in hannover
inszeniert durch die new york times in
der new york times sodann eine chance
die er verpasst eigentlich sich zu
distanzieren jetzt endlich von putin und
er macht das gegenteil also wenn man die
fotos sehen die wir gerade gesehen wenn
gerhard schröder ein treffer wäre würde
er damit bling bling und goldketten und
in etwa das niveau hat ja jetzt auch
grad erreicht also sich in der es in der
situation so nochmal
zu inszenieren und zu zeigen dass er
reue interview gibt sachen glaube ich
schon ganz lange nicht mehr bei gerd
schröder tickt schlicht und ergreifend
so wie wir ihn hier sehen und dann die
wie wir ihn hören und auch immer
vernehmen gerhard schröder ist auf
russischer seite gerhard schröder die
seiten gewechselt und besonders pervers
ist eine aussage die er getroffen hat
dass er gefragt waren nach den
kriegsverbrechen in bussen und an
anderen orten und da hat er gesagt dass
er nicht glaubt dass der befehl von
wladimir putin kommt sondern von unteren
ebenen und das ist wirklich an
perversität und angeblich kaum noch zu
überbieten ging da aus der verantwortung
nehmen das ist deaktiviert butscher ein
komplett also sowohl gutschein wird
relativiert als auch die verantwortung
von wladimir putin der oberbefehlshaber
der russischen stadt kräfte und er hat
den befehl erteilt und zwar allein es
ist zum anfang immer da so dimitri
peskow sein eigener sprecher darauf
bestanden dass jede entscheidung jeder
befehl von bloody mary putin direkt
kommt einfach klar zu machen da sitzt
der wunsch der führer das ist das
russische wort dafür der große starke
mann der da im kreml sitzt und gerhard
schröder schlägt sich voll auf seiner
seite da ist er schon und wenn die
klitschkos jetzt fordern er soll
deutschland verlassen nein er soll mal
schön hier bleiben erst hiervon
hindeuten gewählt worden wir müssen
ihnen vor augen behalten für das total
versagen der deutschen politik jetzt von
den deutschen auch gewählt von die
meisten deutschen sind diesen weg
tatsächlich auch mit gegangen und habe
auch geglaubt das was schröder
steinmeier merkel machen ist das
richtige und wenn wir das so wollen
müssen wir ihn als mahnmal hier quasi
haben und den leuten wie halt an gerhard
schröder lass uns noch mal auf einige
aussagen blicken aus diesen wirklich ja
man muss sagen bewerten und
bemerkenswerten interview bei dem ja
auch so sagt die korrespondenten der new
york times ganz schön viel weiß rhein
geflossen sein soll und er betonte immer
wieder man solle sich nicht von putin
lösen man müsse auch nach dem krieg
wieder zurückkehren das könnte man sich
wirtschaftlich gar nicht erlauben es ist
nicht ansatzweise zu sehen dass er
irgendwelche konsequenzen weder für sich
noch für deutschland aus dieser
situation gerade zieht gehen mal so weit
dass gerhard schröder überhaupt nicht
mehr versteht worum es überhaupt geht
und wo er seinen eigenen fehler
eigentlich lag das hat er schlicht und
ergreifend nicht verstanden das mag
daran liegen dass er die wandelnde wodka
kugel von von wladimir putin ist also
dass da so viel weißwein geflossen ist
das ist nicht umsonst bemerkt wurden
aber
er hat nicht begriffen dass das was er
gemacht hat nicht nur im deutschen
interesse war das war das gegenteil dass
deswegen gegen europa es ging komplett
gegen osteuropa und was gegen europa
angeht ist nicht im deutschen interesse
uns in eine abhängigkeit zu bringen ist
nicht in deutschland interesse und das
konto zu füllen ist nicht im deutschen
interesse gerd schröder hat einzig und
allein in seinem eigenen interesse
gehandelt wir müssen immer daran denken
wir hatten erst vor kurzem enthüllt ganz
früh hatte der kreml ende 98 anfang 99
hat er mit einem plan gefasst gerhard
schröder sich gefügig zu machen ganz
offensichtlich ist er relativ gut
aufgegangen und gerhard schröder konnte
unter wladimir putin zwei kinder aus
russland adoptieren das waren juristisch
heikel es ging gerade so aber der kreml
hat das hat er mir damals selbst aber
eingeräumt eingegriffen und hat das
ermöglicht und da ist halt viel
dankbarkeit da ist viel abhängigkeit und
wer die hat schröder ist halt gerd
schröter die werden wir nicht mehr
ändern wir müssen damit leben dass wir
eine wahre schande als altkanzler wie
jetzt weiter mit gerhard schröder das
ist die entscheidende frage vor allen
dingen für seine partei die weiterhin
seine partei ist die spd nämlich
zufälligerweise auch gerade die
kanzlerpartei die regierungspartei wie
geht sie jetzt mit gerhard schröder oma
mahnt war hierbei bild live in den
richtigen frage zu gast hendrik wüst
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
und der hat noch mal gesagt das ist eine
neuerliche provokation dieses new york
times -interview spätestens
allerspätestens jetzt muss die spd
reagieren
hendrik wüst wollen wir einmal reinhören
in den nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten hier zu gast
von gerd schröder in der new york times
ist schon ziemlich verstörend und das
muss folgen haben die gesamte spd
führung hat gesagt wenn gerhard schröder
an seinen gut bezahlten mandaten bei
putin festhält kann er nicht mehr
mitglied der spd sein jetzt sagt er uns
über ein interview in der new york times
dass er genau das vor hat nämlich seinen
gut bezahlten jobs putin zu behalten und
deswegen ist die spd jetzt aufgerufen
ihren worten taten folgen zu lassen
hannover 96 hat den kanzler schon
ausgeschlossen was hannover 96 kann muss
auch die spd schaffen
so einfach wie beim fussball peter tiede
und chefreporter hier im studio was
glaubst du wie geht das weiter waren
eier da schon so ewig herum distanziert
sich aber auch nicht wirklich eindeutig
und klar mal von gerd schröder es gibt
einige in der spd das muss man zugute
halten die sind aber nicht die erste
reihe sowie michael roth ist außen- und
der außenexperte die sich distanzieren
aber wenn die spd gerhard schröder jetzt
nicht feiert jetzt kein
parteiausschlussverfahren anstrengt dann
ist die spd komplett unglaubwürdig dann
ist auch die verliert auch der kanzler
die neston rest seiner glaubwürdigkeit
und dann verlieren auch die parteichefs
den letzten rest ihrer glaubwürdigkeit
lars klingbeil muss das jetzt machen
auch aus als persönlichen
befreiungsschlag er hat sehr lange sehr
lange für gerd schröder gearbeitet und
er hat selbst in diesem
bundestagswahlkampf noch mit gerhard
schröder wahlkampf gemacht wenn sie sich
jetzt nicht wirklich endgültig los sagt
und ein parteiausschlussverfahren macht
dann klebt das an anlass klingen weil
mit an dem groß schafft der spd und muss
ich bei der spd aber die frage stellen
mit dem wind wir wollen ja die schmeißen
die müssen ja normalerweise auch bei
frau schwesig noch mal ganz genau nach
gucken die ja wirklich in materie oscar
wahl also der spitzname war küsten warm
ich habe schon gesagt sie ist der nummer
troschke also wer sich aufmacht er
findet den kreml drin das was da
gelaufen ist mitten mit 0 2 matthias
platzeck der ehemalige spd-chef vergisst
man ja gerne dass er nicht nur
ministerpräsident von brandenburg war
sondern auch mal kurzzeitig chef der spd
der auch als kreml propagandist unter
einsetzt werk sellering und es geht doch
bis rein in die ganzen landesregierung
brandenburg mecklenburg-vorpommern und
und nach nordrhein-westfalen wir haben
da einen moskauer hannover sucht der ist
bis heute nicht aufgearbeitet worden und
man muss dann aber auch sagen wir haben
ein riesenproblem in der spd das macht
sich an gerhard schröder und der daran
sollen die personen kette fest wir haben
es auch in anderen parteien haben es
auch in der union werden vor allem auch
in der csu aber wenn geld studie da
jetzt nicht aus dieser partei fliegt
dann hat die spd die um
parteivorsitzende co vorsitzende saskia
esken rettet sich aktuell noch raus
dadurch dass sie sagt er soll doch jetzt
bitte austreten aber aktiv in die rolle
der einzugehen die sagen wir wollen dich
hier nicht mehr haben das hat die
spd-spitze ganz offenbar noch nicht
gemacht das hat der kanzler auch ganz
offenbar noch nicht gemacht das ist
feigheit vor dem feind
gerhard schröder noch als freund sieht
gerhard schröder noch als seinen
genossen sieht hier in deutschland in
dieser aktuellen situation der hat nicht
verstanden dass das wort genosse
bedeutet genosse das sind leute die
haben sich schließen sich zusammen die
haben einen gemeinsamen willen wenn wir
aus der spd-führung jetzt noch sagen
kann ich halte das mit den schultern
auch in einer partei aus der muss man
wirklich mal sein standort neu
definieren